you chose joe biden
as the next president of the united
states of america
hillary clinton couldn't be happier
about the 2020
election she took to twitter to
congratulate the next president
joe biden and vice president kamala
harris
writing quote the voters have spoken
it's a history making ticket a
repudiation of trump
and a new page for america clinton who
was a 2016 democratic presidential
nominee
ended her tweet with quote onward
together
we're seeing all over this nation all
cities and all parts of the country
indeed across the world an outpouring of
joy
of hope renewed faith and tomorrow bring
a better day
barack and michelle obama showed their
support for biden and harris too
on instagram the former president shared
his confidence in biden
writing quote we're fortunate that joe's
got what it takes to be president
and already carries himself that way i
know he'll do the job with the best
interests of every american at heart
whether or not
he had their vote obama also encouraged
all americans to give biden a chance
and quote lend him your support as the
election results show
that the country is still quote deeply
and bitterly
divided i pledge to be a president
who seeks not to divide but unify
as for michelle she thanked people for
heading to the polls
and voting in this monumental election
thank you for turning out in record
numbers to make
your voices heard she wrote quote
after we celebrate and we all should
take a moment to exhale
after everything we've been through
let's remember that this is just the
beginning
it's the first step the former first
lady noted that the path to progress
will quote
always be appealed we'll always have to
scrape and
crawl up toward that mountaintop
we can do it i know we can many stars
celebrated joe biden's win
after posting this
chrissy teigen and john legend continue
to celebrate on the streets of
west hollywood california
kim kardashian showed her support for
joe biden's win
despite the failed presidential bid of
her husband
kanye west the reality star tweeted a
photo of biden
and harris together with three heart
emojis
ariana grande took to social media to
share her excitement
the singer posted a video on instagram
of people cheering on the streets
[Applause]
she also tweeted out quote crying thank
god
moments after the news also in tears
jennifer lopez i'm just crying tears of
joy
congratulations that we can all come
together love each other and appreciate
each other
it's a new day the mom of two praised
kamala harris who became the first woman
and first woman of color as vice
president
history is being made today for all
little girls who got loud across the
world
[Music]
it is an amazing amazing day